when people are not going anywhere when
they're when they're failing when
they're when they don't have the drive
it's because they're not accepting
responsibility for anything don't wait
anymore don't think anymore don't plan
anymore don't contemplate anymore don't
make any more excuses I recommend that
you go to bed earlier because we're
doing at night most the time the
motivation what just offend with the
leave mission what's that believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from being a Navy SEALs commander and
receiving the silver and Bronze Star for
his service to becoming an influential
podcaster and author he's jockle willing
and here's my take on his top 50 rules
for success also if you want to know
what Jocko and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below people want to
know how to stop the laziness and they
want to know how to stop the
procrastination
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one attack one of my direct subordinates
one of my guys that work for me he would
he would call me up or pull me aside
with some major problem some issue that
was going on and he'd say Paul so we got
this and that and the other thing and I
look at him I'd say good and finally one
day he was telling me about some issue
that he was having some problem and he
said I already know what you're gonna
say I said well what am I going to say
he said you're gonna say good
he said that's what you always say when
something is wrong in going bad you
always just look at me and say good and
I said well yeah when things are going
bad there's gonna be some good that's
gonna come from it didn't get the new
high speed gear we wanted good didn't
get promoted
[Music]
Oh mission got cancelled good we didn't
focus on the other one didn't get funded
didn't get the job you wanted
injured sprained my ankle got tapped out
good got beat
unexpected problems good
we have the opportunity
to figure out a solution that's it when
things are going bad don't get all
bummed out don't get startled don't get
frustrated
if you can say the word good guess what
it means you're still alive it means
you're still bleeding
and if you're still breathing
or the now
you still got some fight left in you so
get up
Dustoff reload recalibrate re-engage go
out on the attack
rule number two have discipline I always
say that discipline is the loop of all
good qualities but you have to
absolutely apply it to things outside of
just waking up early it's it's
everything it's working out every day
making yourself stronger and faster and
more flexible and healthier discipline
is eating the right foods to a fuel your
system it
it's about disciplining your emotions so
you can make good decisions it's about
having the discipline to control your
ego so your ego doesn't get out of hand
and control you it's about treating
people the way you would want to be
treated and and doing the tasks that you
don't necessarily want to do but that
you know will help you or help your team
it's about facing your fears takes
discipline to face your fears so you can
conquer them and that's what discipline
is discipline means taking the hard road
the uphill road to do what's right for
yourself and for other people it's so
often the easy path the easy path that
calls to us to be weak for that moment
to break down for that moment to give in
to the desire and the short-term
gratification
but the discipline will not allow that
the discipline calls for strength and
fortitude and will it won't accept
weakness it won't tolerate another
breakdown a discipline and seem like
it's your worst enemy but the reality is
discipline is your best friend it will
take care of you like nothing else can
and it'll put you on that path the path
to strength and health and intelligence
and happiness and most importantly it'll
put you on that path to freedom rule
number three take action now people want
to know how to stop the laziness and
they won't know how to stop the
procrastination and you know they have
some idea in their head you know some
kind of a vision what they want to do
but they don't know where to start in
order to start it you know they don't
know where to start and say they say hey
where do I start
and and when's the best time to start
and I have a very simple answer for that
here and now that's it
you you want to improve you want to get
better you want to get on a workout
program or a clean diet you want to
start a business you want to write a
book or make a movie or build a house or
a computer or put together some mobile
application
where do you start you start right here
and when do you start you start right
now you initiate the action aggressively
you go because the idea isn't gonna
execute itself and the book isn't gonna
write itself and the weights out in the
gym they're not gonna move themselves
you have to do it and you have to do it
now and that means you gotta stop
thinking about it and stop dreaming
about it and stop researching every
aspect of it and reading all about it
and debating the pros and cons of it
just start doing it take that first step
and make it happen and get after it and
get after it here and now rule number
four turn weaknesses into strengths a
person's strengths are often their
biggest weaknesses and so that also
means that their weaknesses can be their
strengths so me I am weak in all those
ways that I listed I am weak but I don't
accept that I don't accept that I am
what I am and that that is what I'm
doomed to be no I don't accept that I'm
fighting I'm always fighting I'm
struggling and I'm strapping and I'm
kicking and clawing at those weaknesses
to change them stop them some days I win
some days
don't but each and every day I get back
up and I move forward with my fists
clenched toward the battle toward the
struggle and I fight with everything
I've got to overcome those weaknesses
and those shortfalls and those flaws as
I strive to be just a little bit better
today than I was yesterday rule number
five be focused first of all before the
war the military sent me to college so I
had to go to college and I as I said
earlier as I said before I was super
focused when I went to college I've been
in the SEAL Teams for ten years I was a
go-getter I was a hard charger I was
like oh you want me to read this book
boom I would sit down and just force
myself to read it and then got back to
the SEAL Teams and like like when I went
to college I literally read every single
thing that I was assigned and nobody
does that in college nobody does that
I've read every single page of every
single thing I was assigned during
college that's ridiculous it's almost a
waste of time it's almost embarrassing
EKKO definitely thinks it's a waste of
time but but it was because I just could
just go lock my brain down and get it
done and then get back to the teams into
the teams officer the teams you have a
lot of administrative brain work to do
evaluations and after actions reports
and all these things and I would do the
same thing I just go into lockdown mode
and I put my brain on it and boom I'd go
through it and just get it done I would
just be able to focus so they each thing
laser focus laser focus that report done
God give me a God report done rule
number six kill the quitter instinct
there's another kind of instinct that
you need to be on the lookout for and
this one is a liar this one is a
saboteur well this one is a backbiter
and like the devil himself Visa
shifter he's gonna disguise himself and
make you think he's got your best
interest in mind
but he doesn't this is the instinct that
says you've had enough this is the
instinct that says you've you've given
it your best shot
you can you can stand down you can back
off you can take a knee this is the
instinct it says you can rest now do not
listen to that instincts do not listen
that instinct is a liar and wants to
bring you down that that's the instinct
that's a defense mechanism it wants to
give you an out place to run to
a little little place of sympathy an
amnesty a little place of amnesty where
everything is forgiven where all these
these failures can gather together and
comfort and drown their sorrows in lies
and in deception and they tell each
other and they'll tell you you did the
best you could know they'll say the dock
the deck the deck was stacked against
you and they'll say it's not your fault
and they'll tell you it's okay to stop
it's okay to settle it's okay to give up
and that is the instinct you need to
fight you need to push back to smash
into the ground do not take the easy way
out do not give up based on instinct if
you are forced to stand down
to retreat so that you can rebuild
Andrea tak so be it but make that
decision based on logic not on the
instinct of surrender and defeat and you
need to train that instinct your
instinct train it to say get up go fight
on and if that is what you become if
that becomes your fundamental reaction
to adversity if that becomes your gut
instinct then you will overcome just
about anything that stands in your path
rule number seven take advantage of
stress there's been thousands and
hundreds of thousands and millions of
warriors that have been in very
stressful situations and faced evil and
faced death much worse than the
situation I'm in or a year in that we
might consider stressful and I even did
this when I was overseas when I was on
deployment when I was a combat leader I
was feeling stress and you know what we
took casualties and it was awful and it
was heartbreaking and but there
or other soldiers and warriors
throughout time that have been in much
worse situations Gettysburg or Vicksburg
or the Battle of the Bulge and in all
those horrible situations they prove
really that humans can withstand almost
most unimaginable stress which meant to
me that I could - and you can and the
first step for me is doing that taking
that look to gain some perspective and
then in order to gain perspective you
got to do something that we already
talked about you've got a detach you've
got to detach from the problems or the
stress that you're experiencing so that
you can get that perspective of them now
there's a couple different types of
stress now if it's something that you
can control that's causing you stress
well why aren't you getting control of
it now there's also stress that's caused
by things that you cannot control and if
you remember talking earlier about
artillery and how horrible that was and
what made it so horrible was that
there's no control over so if you can't
control something and you can't get
control of it you have to at least
embrace what you can and I'm not saying
you're gonna embrace artillery shelling
but I'll tell you what when it comes to
things like artillery or for us in
Ramadi was IEDs and we could do
everything we could do to mitigate that
risk but eventually there's only so much
you can do and you cannot completely
eliminate it
but you can't control it so why you
gonna worry about it
why are you gonna stress about it if
there's something that's completely
beyond your control
you cannot you've got to detach from it
and not let yourself get stressed about
it and on top of that if it's something
that you can't control how can you look
at it in a different light how can you
see it in a way that you could actually
take advantage of it how can you take
that stress and make it into some kind
of a lie you know the the chaos of
combat is something that I couldn't
control but I had to embrace it so I
could try and figure out how to take
advantage of it so when it comes to
stress don't fight it
turn it on itself and use it use it use
it to make yourself sharper and more
alert and use it to make yourself think
more and learn more and get better and
use that stress as a catalyst to make
yourself better rule number eight just
do it your book isn't i mean it's thick
but i should have been able to read this
in two or three solid days of read yes i
told you how successful I was yes not
very and that bugs the [ __ ] Adam and I
it's a it's a it's a it's a fail it's a
it's a you know what though I think this
is a failure in my part I I think that
this is the same thing we were talking
about on the last podcast and I think
echo said when you say oh you know what
I'm not gonna finish this book right now
it's it I don't really want to it's sort
of like when you say oh I'm not gonna
it's not that I want to though that's
what I'm saying you say but I don't want
to do it right now I can push it off a
little bit you accept that do you accept
that answer
mm-hmm you accept that answer the
soldier
Jodee right wouldn't accept that answer
would not do you self-talk not really
not really I'm not a guy that says you
know I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do that
I just do it right I'll just go and do
whatever that thing is rule number nine
step towards your fear you know I
actually took this question from Twitter
and I answered the question in one word
you've lived a life dominated by doubt
and fear how do you step into bravery
step that's how you step into bravery
step take the step step aggressively
towards your fear and that that step
towards your fear is the step into
bravery because we're per scared of what
we don't know and there is only one way
to learn and to know and that is to
confront that fear you have to step you
have to go and this simple action this
simple attitude it answers so many
questions
my theory here would be if you're afraid
of fighting and altercations go change
it so if you're afraid of heights work
on some rock climbing climbing if you're
afraid of the water time to swim it's
time to surf it's time to get out there
if you're afraid of pull-ups if if
you're afraid of pulps do pull-ups if
you're in squats do squats if you're
afraid of public speaking go speak in
public mm-hmm if you're afraid to start
a business start a business make it
small and on all these what you have to
do is you have to mitigate the risk and
you have to ease yourself into it
but you got to go for it and eventually
you will overcome that fear but the hard
part is you got to take that first step
you got to take that first step to begin
to inoculate yourself against the fear
against the fear of the thing that's in
your mind because that fear generally is
in your mind yeah you know when you get
up on stage do a public speaking people
are not gonna throw tomatoes at you and
say oh my you're an idiot get off the
stage no they're gonna sit there you
know so there's nothing to fear yeah
it's in it's in your head
rule number 10 practice every day I
tweeted at Java where I asked him if
you'd like to take part in a fitness
challenge he graciously came with a
counteroffer
and said how about a graphic match for
some reason I said yes and so here I am
now it's a indigo
[Music]
[Applause]
okay you can't have it
you actually have to get choked out so
there is
[Applause]
nice victory for ya you know really
honestly it's just cause I've been
training for a long time then I have
that skill set you know it's something
that anybody could get is not because
I'm special it's just cuz I trained for
a long time doing this and if the roles
were reversed and he's been training
longer than me that's the way it works
yeah real number 11 make every second
count
rome wasn't built in a day we all know
that everyone's hears that but rome also
didn't fall apart overnight either it
took hundreds of years for Rome to reach
its peak but it also took time hundreds
of years for Rome to decay and fall
apart and that is representative of life
because you don't achieve worthwhile
goals quickly or easily they take time
they take struggle they take relentless
pursuit day in and day out that's what
it takes but also things don't usually
fall apart quickly either at least at
first it's it's a slow process a little
slip here a little setback over there a
little wearing down of discipline and
will over time
that's the thing success and failure are
generally slow processes either slowly
building things up or gradually tearing
them down and that's why I say you've
got to pay attention you have to watch
you have to watch every single second
because those seconds they turn into
minutes then minutes turn into hours and
hours turn into days and days turn in to
years and so that second that second
that just went by that counted and so
did that second and so did that one
and in those precious seconds you're
either building or you're decaying you
were either gaining ground or you were
losing ground in that second
and in every second
every second counts
so make every second count rule number
12 take ownership when a team takes
ownership of its problems the problems
get solved and that is true on the
battlefield it is true in business and
it is true in life so I say take
ownership take extreme ownership don't
make excuses don't blame any other
person or any other thing get control of
your ego don't hide your delicate pride
from the truth take ownership of
everything in your world the good and
the bad take ownership of your mistakes
take ownership of your shortfalls take
ownership of your problems and then take
ownership of the solutions that will get
those problems solved take ownership of
your mission take ownership of your job
of your team of your future and take
ownership of your life and lead lead
lead yourself and your team and the
people in your life lead them all to
victory rule number 13 cast out the lies
the chronic excuse maker how do you stop
making excuses this is actually pretty
simple and I said it the other day and
you have to realize you have to know you
have to accept that all your excuses are
lies they are lies all of them think
about the things that you tell yourself
the lies you used to rationalize taking
the easy road taking the easy road and
leaving discipline behind think about
them you don't have time that's a lie
you don't have support that's a lie you
don't have the equipment or the gear
lies you don't you don't know the best
way who cares that's a lie or you're too
old or you're too young of course you're
too old or too young lie and there's
you're too busy sure you are that's high
and you're too tired or you're too sore
or you're just plain not feeling it lies
lies lies and the list goes on and on
and on then it doesn't stop if you don't
make it stop so recognize recognize
the excuses are not valid
they aren't they're trumped-up they're
conjured up they're fabricated their
lies and how do you stop the lies you
stop the lies with the truth the truth
the truth will set you free the truth
will stand and the truth will deliver
you from procrastination and laziness
and the downward spiral that comes with
a lack of discipline so don't believe
the lies believe the truth and the truth
is you have time you have the skill you
have the knowledge and the support and
the willpower and the discipline to get
it done so cast out the lies burn them
down and listen to the truth and live
the truth and go out and get it done
rule number 14 stop looking for
shortcuts I don't really like those
words self help or self management or
self-improvement I don't really like
what those words have come to mean these
days because there's a lot of people out
there that are constantly trying to
improve themselves by looking for the
one change the one change right the one
change in their life that's gonna make
their dreams come true and even worse on
top of that there's a lot of people out
there a lot of self-help gurus and these
hyperactive motivational speakers and
these other self-appointed modern Zen
yoga warriors that they're trying to
sell the one thing they're trying to
sell the nine steps or the enlightened
path
it's gonna allow you to unlock all of
your human potential and fulfill the
dreams so you can live the life that
you've you've always wanted to live
now I'm no guru and I definitely don't
claim to be I'm just a man but I will
tell you this it isn't one thing and it
isn't ten things and it isn't a hundred
things it isn't
a quick path and there are no shortcuts
the meditation won't get you there and
neither will a miracle drug or an
organic supplement or some superfood
getting better isn't a hack or a trick
or one change that you need to make
getting better is a campaign it's a
campaign it's a daily a weekly it's an
hourly fight an incessant fight that
doesn't stop against weakness and
against temptation and against laziness
it's a campaign of discipline the
campaign of hard work and dedication
it's waking up early and going to bed
late and grinding out every second in
between every single day so you want to
get better you want to self-improve stop
looking for a shortcut and go find your
alarm clock and find your discipline and
fling your guts and your passion and
your drive and find it you will and then
and then you will find your freedom
rule number 15 prioritize and execute
when things go wrong they always seem to
happen at once
and they just compound on top of each
other and it's it's pretty easy
sometimes to to feel beaten when you're
faced with all those issues and all
those problems and they all hit you at
the same time but let me tell you that
that doesn't mean give up in fact it
means the opposite it means it's time
for you to fight harder to dig in means
it's time for you to go on the warpath
and that starts with one of the
fundamental laws of combat leadership
prioritize and execute what's the
biggest problem what's causing the most
stress family okay
sit them down explain where you are at
the blunt be upfront and then give them
the simple plan of how you're gonna get
things back on track don't sugarcoat it
you give it to him straight next you've
got some some late payments call those
creditors up explain to them what's
going on set up some kind of a low of a
minimum payment plan so you can start
making some progress and get them off
your back and then you got your job
right you're falling behind at work okay
talk to your boss
face it tell him that you're gonna step
up your game tell him you're gonna be at
work early you're gonna be at work late
you're gonna be at work during lunch
you're gonna be wherever you need to be
whenever he needs you to be there tell
him you're gonna get after it
and tell them that you're a hundred
percent committed to supporting him and
the company and the mission
and then you get started
rule number 16 hold the line I keep
getting asked this type of question how
do I get discipline or how do I want
discipline or how do I maintain
discipline and the answer it's it's a
simple answer but obviously it's not
easy and there's all kinds of little
tricks and methods that people talk
about and you know they have some merit
you know maybe they do work these these
things you know do the little things
people say and wake up early I say that
and write things down and take cold
showers and tell everyone what you're
going to do so broadcast it and make
promises or or make bets with with your
friends of something that you don't want
to lose and those things those ideas
they're cool I'm sure they're gonna have
some impact and if they work for you
that's that's awesome but but the fact
of the matter is that the reason
discipline is hard to maintain is
because it is hard to maintain that's
what makes discipline hard it's hard and
if you hear me claim that discipline is
easy for me then straight up that's just
my ego talking that's what that is
because I'm unfortunately just as human
as everyone else and it is work to
maintain the discipline that's what it
is work holding the line maintaining the
standard giving no slack none that's the
discipline
[Music]
that's the discipline and it is hard and
if there's one thing I would say that
does make it easier it's to envision
what it feels like when you're done what
it feels like after you've worked out or
you've held the line on your food intake
or you've pushed through some monotonous
project that you have to do and all
those things when they're done that they
feel good and contrary to that envision
what you will feel like later when you
let the discipline slack you know the
feeling feeling weak and defeated and
you know that you're falling behind so
get to know those two different types of
feelings and ask yourself which one you
want to feel in ten minutes or in a half
an hour when when the thing is done when
the discipline has Blin implemented
remember what that feels like and then
remember that those minutes and those
hours they turn into weeks and months
and years and holding the line in those
political minutes will put you in an
infinitely better place physically and
mentally if you maintain the discipline
rule number 17 do not overthink things
tactics to flank flesh shift a ferocious
analyzer from paralysis to go
meaning what some over things it's the
landing and planning and planning and
planning well
a couple things here if the person is
above you or below you in the chain of
command so if they're below you in the
chain of command you you know you
explain to them you say look we don't
need perfection we're not gonna have
100% solution we don't have 4% of the
information that's a good enough
solution we need to move forward let's
execute and you know what I'll take root
of things go wrong wrong don't worry
about it I'll take responsibility for it
I'm not gonna blame you which is what
you're gonna do anyways as a good leader
so that's what you can do if you letter
below you in the chain of command if
they're above you in the chain of
command guess what
same thing you gonna tell the same thing
like a boss we don't need perfection
here look boss we're not gonna get all
the information we need we're not gonna
get a hundred percent solution we got a
90 percent solution and let's go for it
and if things do go wrong you can blame
me I don't care so boom the weather that
are above your you know below you the
chain of command you might change your
tact or your verbage a little bit but
it's the same same overall concept
you've got to get them to understand
that we don't need perfection we need to
move forward and the other thing is you
explained the cost of not moving the
cost of staying still the cost of being
reactive instead of proactive in
basically the cost of not being
aggressive because that's what we're
talking about as a lack of aggression
and so what does that look like well you
explain to them that the longer we sit
the better position the enemy gets into
the longer we wait the less we know
about what is actually happening think
about that one the more you sit here and
you're planning the less we know what's
going on out there the things are
happening they're changing they're
evolving the enemy is maneuvering
there's developments on the battlefield
or in the marketplace and you don't even
know because you're sitting in the
planning space mmm the longer we wait
the less time we have to recover if
something does go wrong
mmm so if we sit here and plan for 47
days and on the 40th day we set out we
start to execute something goes wrong
we're not gonna make the 50 day markers
we will just spend all that time
planning so the longer that you're
sitting around the last time you have to
recover and adapt and adjust and the
longer that you wait while you're doing
planning the less relevant your plan
actually becomes
so that's what you need to make people
understand
rule number 18 stay on the warpath those
days when I'm tired or worn out or just
basically sick of the grind well what do
I do on those days I go anyways I get it
done even if I'm just going through the
motions I go through the motions I don't
really want to work out I work out I
really don't want to hammer on a project
I hammer on the project don't really
want to get up and get out of bed yeah I
get up and get out of bed now these
could be signals that you need some time
off and those signals might be right
they could be correct but don't take
today off not today wait until tomorrow
don't don't give in to the immediate
gratification that is whispering in your
ear shut that down do not listen to that
little voice instead go through the
motions lift the weights sprint the hill
work on the project get out of bed now
as an overall rule I do not like
procrastination you need to get things
done but if you are going to rest that
is one thing that you should
procrastinate on that's the one thing I
want you to pull it off until tomorrow
and if when tomorrow comes you still
feel like you need
to rest or you need to take a break then
okay
take it but the chances are you won't
you won't need that rest chances are you
will realize that the desire to rest was
just weakness it was just the desire to
take the path of least resistance that
downhill path the easy path and by
simply going through the motions you
overcame that path and you stayed on the
righteous path
the disciplined path there stayed on the
warpath which is right where you know
that you belong rule number 19 do the
right thing you know for me character is
not a very complex thing for me
character is you do what's right you do
what's right you do the right thing
that's what you do and if you do the
right thing regardless of what the
consequences are that that represents
character and so then how do you build
character it's a beautiful thing because
it's the same thing if you want to build
character you do the right thing you do
the right thing for yourself you do the
right thing for your family you do the
right thing for your the people that you
know you do the right thing for your
community you do the right thing for
your country that's what you do and now
on an individual level
those things are hard things often right
if those are hard things you have to
make the right decisions you have to
live a disciplined life those build
character those little things that you
do on a daily basis to make yourself
better to improve your health to improve
your your situation in life you're doing
those things they're hard to do and when
you do those things they built your
character and ultimately they lead to
your character being a good character as
opposed to a bad one rule number 20 act
strategically the big thing in jiu-jitsu
from my
effective is that you don't go strength
against strength right if I don't if I'm
trying to choke you I don't try and
choke you overtly I don't just grab your
neck no I work on your arm and I put
pressure over here and I past your guard
and then I eventually while you're
thinking about something else
boom that's when I grab your neck or
that's when I grab your arm and that's
what I think on the battlefield you know
you can't you just don't attack hardened
positions of the enemy and in life you
know if you're trying to be a leader
you're trying to step up and lead
somebody you don't just come down in arc
orders at people because that's not as
effective as maneuvering and adjusting
your position and getting in a better
position and then getting that person to
give you what you want instead of trying
to take it from them yeah that's a
really important lesson for Parenthood
like you can't just tell kids what to do
you know like just do it cuz I told you
to do it they're like you I'm gonna be a
hooker and that applies not only to kids
Agera your honor percent it applies to
kids but it applies to adults as well
and that is people need to understand
why they're doing what they're doing it
and you know if I want you to go take
down some building and capture some bad
guy I don't go hey hey Joe I want you to
take down this building once your pack
captures bad guy these are the guys I
want you to take with you here's the
route I want you to take in here's the
methodology I want you to use for the
clearance because then when I send you
to go do that mission it's not your
mission it's my mission I came up with a
plan you didn't so you might be you
might have thought there was a better
way to do it or you might had a
different idea of how to get it done and
now when you go out there and you meet
some kind of resistance whether it's an
obstacle you didn't expect or whether
it's some scenario that you didn't
foresee instead of you trying to
overcome it you just blame me you just
look that jockle came up with this
stupid plan and here we are it's failing
forget it we're going back we're not
going to carry out the mission whereas
if I said hey Joe here's what I want you
to do go figure out the best way to do
it and now you come up with a plan and
now you make up all the methodology of
how you're gonna get it done and you
decide who you're gonna take with you
now it's your plan you own that plan and
when you go out in the field and you
meet a little resistance guess what you
do you said I'm going to find a way
around it I'm gonna overcome this I'm
gonna overcome that obstacle and make it
happen
and that's another piece of leadership
and it's the exact same thing with kids
if you tell your kid you know you will
get good grades in school that means
nothing to them but if you explain to
them hey I I would love for you to get
good grades and here's why it's gonna
open opportunities for you in the future
it's gonna allow you to be able to
outsmart people because you have more
knowledge than them and then you're
gonna be able to end up making more
money which is actually give you more
freedom in the long run instead of doing
a job that you don't want to do you
explain all those things to a kid it's
gonna be a lot more successful than just
do what I told you get good grades
because I said so
rule number 21 be strong and I know I've
said before that knowledge is the most
important thing but the reality is if
you don't have the strength or actually
the health to back that up or even to
function as a human being physically
then your knowledge and your mental
strength doesn't really even matter so
that comes into play and being big and
strong is also totally useless if you're
mentally weak and you quit now being
mentally strong should actually lead you
to being physically strong because if
you are mentally strong then you can
work and train to become physically
strong but if you're mentally weak then
you will not hold the line on the good
food and the good workouts and you won't
get physically strong or healthy so can
you be weak and strong at the same time
yes but I say be strong train your
physical strength and exercise your
mental strength by doing the right
things the hard things the things you
know you're supposed to do do them
and be as strong as you can mentally
physically and emotionally for yourself
for your team for your family hold the
line and be strong rule number 22 find
your mission you know when you're in the
military you have this discipline and
beyond that beyond the discipline that's
imposed on you you also have a lot that
you have to just hold the line yourself
I mean when you're in the military sure
you go through boot camp where there's a
drill instructor the challenge and all
that but once you're in the military
you're doing what you have to do it's
self-discipline that you learn that then
you become self-discipline and what
happens is guys get out and that's
that's gone and that hurts them and the
other thing that hurts them is they
don't know what their mission is anymore
and and my big thing with people that
have been telling vets now is find what
your next mission is go find whatever
your next mission and I don't care what
it is but it has to be something when
people are not going anywhere when
they're when they're failing when
they're when they don't have the drive
it's because they're not accepting
responsibility for anything and and so
my way of saying that is like you need a
new mission you can't be responsible for
something and you need to go and move
towards some new mission
rule number 23 have short and long term
goals don't know you can't know how
you're gonna conduct a war before the
war starts you can have an idea but you
can't know fully just like if you were
to say hey my goal is 2x in my life you
don't know how you're gonna be able to
do that because you talkin about cuz you
gotta just be here gonna make it
adaptations are gonna come up things are
gonna change the battlefield changes
your life changes things pop up mean
things happen so I think that that idea
that you're gonna know how you're gonna
execute something is is far-fetched I
think you want actually I should use the
word idea you should have an idea of how
you're gonna do it yeah you should have
an idea like okay well this is what I
need to get done this is what I want to
achieve in my life yeah I want to make I
want to do this mm-hmm what's a simple
one
I want to own a house that's a simple
one that's a good place to start yeah I
want to own a house okay well let's
think about how we're gonna get there
you know that's that's this thing about
how we're gonna get there you have to
build your credit you have to have how
do you build your credit you have to you
have to borrow money some people
something they go to buy a house they've
never borrowed money before you can't
borrow money if you've never borrowed
money you can't borrow money for a house
if you've never borrowed money for a car
or or or some smaller object before so
you got to establish your credit then
you got to have two years worth of
income then you got to have a big fat
downpayment sitting ready so there's
things you got to do this thing now now
that might change the clock along the
way the idea is that you got to move
towards that goal that's what was so
nice about hearing the vietnamese
commander's intent get close split them
up mmm boom you go make that happen
hey guess what you want to buy a house
one day save money have good credit yeah
okay well you got to make money how
you'd make money you might make it drive
it
uber you might make it delivering pizza
you might make it you got your real job
with that support in your family but
then you need a little extra to throw in
there well that's why you end up driving
uber you end up with whatever it is
you're gonna do you wanna make your some
money on the side that you can start
stashing away so you got it in a way you
got to fill your life with a bunch of
goals so you don't get gem cuz you have
small goals that lead to the big goal
right so for instance you want to be
financially secure and stable what are
you gonna do you're gonna save some of
your money okay that's one thing you're
gonna buy a house that's another thing
you're gonna pay off your car and you're
not gonna buy expensive dumb cars you're
gonna buy cheap cars until you have the
money to buy him with cash
you're gonna make all these little
things you're gonna work extra you're
gonna you know you're gonna do these
things so you're right you have you have
your broad goal yes you have your
long-term goal yes and then you got your
short-term goals that lead and are
strategically aligned with that
long-term goal rule number 24 show and
earn respect I just gotta ask this
question the other day young
construction business and a kid we were
in a big meeting with a with a bunch of
leadership foremen two engineers all in
the same room bunch of great guys from a
great company and each one of the young
engineers raised his hand and said you
know I'm young and I am gonna be in
charge of these guys you know
sure I'm comfortable with these guys
have been doing it for a lot longer what
can I do to you know gain their respect
and I said okay who in this room knows
more than that engineer back there about
construction and all B's salty
construction the Foreman's raised their
hands and I said whoo you know who's
gonna think that this guy's got the best
idea raise your hands all the hands go
down and I said so this is what you're
dealing with buddy
I said now let me ask another question
the group group if this kid comes in and
says I know how to do this better than
you listen to me and do it my way
who's gonna have respect for him raise
your hand no hands go up if this young
kid comes in and says hey I'm an
engineer I've been educated but I
haven't been doing this for long can you
give me some recommendations on how we
do this so we can do the best job
possible who's gonna have respect for
everyone raises their hand so there you
have it
you you you don't have to know
everything as a leader no one expects
you know everything especially as a
young leader that's okay and actually
when you admit that you actually gain
respect when you ask for people as input
you actually gain respect people get the
paranoid feeling that if they don't know
something they're gonna be seen as weak
it's not true so you can just step up
into the position still be humble still
take advice now this doesn't mean that
you're a pushover right this doesn't
mean that you just listen to what
everyone says you don't make any
decisions no but it actually means that
you show respect to their experience and
when it comes time to make a decision
you get the best input and then you make
a decision and you explain your decision
and if your decision is wrong you admit
it and if it's not wrong you push
forward
rule number 25 have balance I look like
a serial killer for all practical
purposes I'm that's the way I come
across right no it was not creepy enough
there's there's guys that would you know
guys that would work for me or guys that
would be around me and they'd see me and
they'd kind of latch on to the fact that
I was tough and aggressive and and and
some of those guys they wouldn't catch
the other part which was that I was
politically savvy and I was working and
I was maneuvering and I was you know
figuring things out and talking to my
boss in such a way that we could get
where we needed to be and I was doing
that whole other side and so I get these
guys that would end up not doing as well
as they should do because they were just
a jock was just ultra aggressive and he
gets after it and so that's what I'm
gonna do and I'll be in the same place
the guys that would do well the guys
that said oh yeah jock was awesome and
he's aggressive and he gets after he's
also working and he's also maneuvering
he's also massaging the egos of the
people around him to make sure that they
get in positioned in the right spot
where they can go to warp off in the
right way and and so as I've gotten
older I've been able to tell people that
more clearly like hey it's not just
about that side of the ultra-aggressive
you got to be aggressive you got to be
willing to fight you got to be willing
to kill and you got to be willing to die
at the same time you gotta be able to
tamper and temper all those things in
such a way that they can be controlled
and disciplined rule number 26 know when
to detach should someone always be
detached okay straightforward question
the answer is no someone shouldn't
always be detached because otherwise you
aren't enjoying anything in your life so
don't always be attached detached no but
at the same time that being said you
should be aware all the time if you are
getting sucked into the emotional vortex
right you've got to be aware of that
once you have that awareness you don't
need to be attached all the time at all
you can I'm not always detached at all
but but I've got clear warning signs
when things start going sideways and I
start going down some vortex I know
immediately I just a - so it's really
easy it's but it's it does take practice
and eventually you realize that
you know when you're feeling overwhelmed
when you're feeling emotional and you're
feeling angry or you're feeling
frustrated when you start feeling those
things and you've sent them really
quickly and you recognize them you just
detach boom you're done yeah so that's
what you got to do is start recognizing
those red flags so that you can enjoy
the good things and when something
starts getting crazy you can detach yes
what's like a overall skill of being
able to control when to detach and when
you don't have to being able to identify
yeah when you need to detach yeah then
being able to detach then you're good
rule number 27 ask for help when needed
as a leader at what point am I allowed
to go to others and say I need you
because I recognize I'm not capable of
pushing toward forward on my own or
should that be an instance where I need
to take a step back and apply more
discipline into my life and find a way
to push forward by myself okay you are
allowed to say that to your team member
immediately that you need them
absolutely if you of course you need
your team because if you didn't need
your team why would they be there yeah
you know if you can do everything
yourself then you don't have a team Yeah
right you just do everything yourself so
while you of course should be working Rd
you should be applying discipline as a
leader it's your job to actually lead
things and to let other people support
and make things happen and there's
nothing wrong with that you and also you
don't want to be stuck in the weeds
doing my new things so if you're not
capable I think what might be holding
this individual back there's two things
number one is I feel like I should take
extreme ownership of everything hmm I
feel like I should just do everything
myself that is not what extreme
ownership is extreme ownership isn't
doing everything yourself and also what
can come into play is your ego because
you don't want to ask people for help
and that's not a good sign there's
nothing wrong with asking people for
help if you need it in fact that's the
humble thing to do hey echo I don't know
how to quite finish out this you know
this thing of this project Morgan how
can you give me a hand with this I don't
know how to work a video recorder you
can you show me how to do that right
whatever so there's no problem with that
you're allowed to ask you can you can
say that immediately in fact your team
should feel that you are counting on
them and relying on them they should
know that and then for your ego aside
ask for help no problem
that doesn't mean you're giving away
that doesn't mean you're not taking
ownership that doesn't mean you're not
applying discipline it means you're
working as a team together to accomplish
mission again if a if a mission is so
easily that you can accomplish it
yourself
you don't need a team why do you have
them hmm if you can do it all yourself
just by applying discipline cool we
don't need anyone else if you're you but
your mission should be larger than one
human being can accomplish so that's why
you have other people on board to help
you out yeah no problem
rule number 28 take responsibility
trying to think of how to stop the loop
of my sacrifices have been rejected and
and the way that you stop that loop is
instead of saying this my sacrifices
were rejected so my hard work my effort
my everything that I'm doing to try and
move forward it's not working and and if
you want to go towards hell you keep
saying well it's it's not working but
it's not it's because of everyone else
it's they're rejecting me they're not
accepting what I've done whereas if you
say to yourself oh it didn't work okay
it's my fault what can I do better and
that's how you start moving in the other
direction
rule number 29 be a good team player
[Music]
we work together as a team and enables
us not only to survive a situation like
that but actually dominate the first law
of combat that we talk about is called
cover and move which means if life and I
are going to assault a target you know
over there I'll get in a good firing
position I'll engage the enemy and keep
their heads down where they can't shoot
back and while I'm doing that
Lafe will get up and maneuver to a
better position cover and move
essentially is teamwork working together
in full support of the other parts of
the team some of the things that can
make teamwork fall apart number one
those individual elements can get
fixated target fixation inside their own
world if I'm here trying to engage the
enemy and all of a sudden I get so
focused on that that I forget about life
and I forget about what he's doing all
of a sudden I'm no help to him anymore
sometimes it can come with ego where I
want to outperform life even though one
on the same team
I want out performing with my element
maybe I do some things that actually
sabotage them I know that sounds crazy
but it happens it definitely happens it
happens in the SEAL team sometimes and
it definitely happens in the corporate
world and we've seen them
rule number thirty get on track I hear
that I'm over 40 I'm pushing 50 whatever
bring it
back off negative not happening in fact
stepping it up
traded harder cleaner
[Music]
I'm learning and reading and studying
more now than I ever have in my whole
life do I get dinged up of course I do
you know what no factor no factor deal
with them
what I hear I hear
that's what I hear
we know man
and you young guns out there
18 years old 20 years old 24 years old
listen
life goes by
goom's
at least those years don't waste them
much less 40 but you are thank you
earlier you get in the game
better life
healthier wealthier stronger smarter
better
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you put an old man like me then you
haven't gone on track yet get on track
get on it now
here's the deal no complacency no
complacency no backing off
no slack whatsoever fight
[Applause]
[Music]
fight that chicken clock with everything
you've got
so
in the heart big
[Applause]
satisfied rule number 31 step
aggressively towards your fear you've
lived a life dominated by doubt and fear
how do you step into bravery step that's
how you step into bravery step take the
step step aggressively towards your fear
and that that step towards your fear is
the step into bravery because we're /
scared of what we don't know and there's
only one way to learn and to know and
that is to confront that fear you have
to step you have to go and this simple
action this simple attitude it answers
so many questions so many questions how
do you get to the gym every day you step
you go how do you how do you change your
diet you step you go how do you overcome
fear of failure fear of success or or
fear of fear itself
you step and how do you face the fear of
the unknown your step don't wait anymore
don't think anymore don't plan anymore
don't contemplate anymore don't make any
more excuses or justifications don't
rationalize anything else no no and no
instead be aggressive take action now
and what is the first action that you
need
to take what's the first step you need
to take the first step you need to take
is just that step rule number three to
out fight the enemy it is not easy to
identify the enemy in combat in war so
what you have to do is you have to
control what you can control
right you got to be prepared you've got
to train you've got to study
you've got to rehearse you've got to
remain vigilant you've got to maintain
discipline and everything you do so that
when the enemy does reveal itself you
have the ability to think it to out
maneuver to out fight the enemy and it's
actually the same thing in business
right the enemy can be hard to identify
your competitors aren't broadcasting
their next move you don't know what the
markets gonna do you can't be certain
about the next trend or the next
downturn or the next bubble that's gonna
burst you can't know those things so you
have to do the same thing after control
what you can control which is you gotta
gather intelligence you got to analyze
the metrics that you can track you got
to train yourself and your team to be
prepared for both the known and also be
prepared for the unknown figure out what
the likely contingencies are then have
some plans to execute if those
contingencies occur maintain discipline
as an organization so that you have the
flexibility and the responsiveness to
maneuver effectively and efficiently
when the unpredictable actually happens
so instead of suffering and falling
apart in the chaos you can take
advantage of it and win
and that business and life is the same
the enemy is not always clear in life it
can be hard to tell who's gonna try and
bring you now or what is going to bring
you down there's distractions there are
things out there that will do you harm
that are so camouflaged you can't see
them at all
there are deceitful people there are
accidents that can occur and diseases
that take root and there's bad luck and
there's Murphy's lawn there's times when
it seems that the whole world is against
you
the whole world is the enemy and the
same rules apply control what you can't
control you train hard learn maintain
the unmitigated daily discipline in all
things
rule number 33 don't go against your
values is it ever okay to violate core
values to achieve a goal okay so first
of all really obvious your values and
your goals should be aligned they should
not be adversarial they shouldn't be
counter to each other and if you think
about what your goals are your goals
should be set up in a way that they
support your values and vice versa
that's just the way it is so I'm not
sure where this is gonna be an issue if
you're setting up goals that are
contrary to your values you've got some
issues now I guess if you had the goal
of winning the blue belt jiu-jitsu
championships and in order to win you
you cheated like you claimed someone was
weeping your leg and use it on you tap
and you get the guy who qualified and
you win that's could be an example right
yeah now do I support that no you know
that's wrong you you go in against the
values of actually the values of martial
arts to do that so you
win anything and you didn't achieve your
goal because you weren't actually the
best so I say no on that one uh another
one let's say you wanted to make a
certain level of profit at your company
so you cheated a little bit on the
quality of the manufacturing and you
sold items that weren't quite reliable
do I support that no right for animal
and why let me tell you why because your
goal your goal is not even aligned with
your goal itself because when you start
making substandard manufactured items
what's gonna happen in the long run keep
I'm gonna say we don't like these yeah
we're not gonna buy them anymore so you
didn't win you might have wanted the
short term but you didn't win and and
again you're going against your value
you should have values that you don't
want to you know take profit over making
good product and again in the long run
that value is gonna cost you right
people aren't gonna want to buy your
product anymore
rule number 34 have a mission I need a
mission we all need a mission that's
what life should be is a mission that's
what gives your life purpose and focus
and drive and ultimately satisfaction
now that mission can be the job you work
at it can be providing for your family
or it can be getting better at jiu-jitsu
or stronger at Olympic lifting or
starting a business that you want to
grow and build and take over the world
and sometimes people ask me what to do
if they don't know what their mission is
or what their mission should be and I
tell them if they're in that situation
to go help someone go help someone else
make that your mission because that will
make you better and it'll make the world
better
and eventually from that you'll see what
your mission is
rule number 35 detach and refine how do
self awareness self assessment and self
improvement
begin and how do they continue over time
try to imagine the way other people see
you and what other people are thinking
of you and one place where this happens
and it definitely happened to me is when
I started getting put in charge of
things I started thinking about other
people's perspectives what are they
seeing if you're in charge then what are
your subordinates see you do what are
your subordinates here you say what kind
of representation are they receiving in
if you work for someone else it's the
same questions what does the boss see me
do what does the boss hear me say what
kind of representation am i making of
myself to my boss and then you start
thinking about what are your friends and
family think what do they see what do
they hear and so the question becomes
how well do you represent yourself what
shortfalls do you have now when you
first start looking it's like you're
looking at an overgrown lawn there are
some big obvious problems so you do a
broad just kind of general cut of the
grass you fix some of the big easy
problems that are obvious but once
you've done that once you've gotten rid
of some of those big obvious problems
you notice some more detailed problems
say then you handle them and once you've
got those handled you see even smaller
and more detail the issues so you start
trying to fix them
and that's what you do with yourself you
continually detach and then you look and
then you refine and then you detach and
then you look and then you refine and
then you detach and you look and then
you refine that's what you do that's how
you get better and that process doesn't
stop it can't stop because if you stop
refining then then the weeds grow back
and the next thing you know you can't
see yourself anymore I mean you can't
see yourself anymore when you stop
looking at you yourself then you accept
[Music]
you accept anything then that's wrong
don't accept the faults don't give
yourself the benefit of the doubt you've
got to be your own harshest critic and
hold the line rule number 36
start small I say this to people all the
time most important here is it isn't me
it's you and sure you may have grabbed
some little foothold from the podcast or
from one of the books but it isn't me
that changes you it's you you set the
small goals you achieve those goals then
set some more and achieve those and set
some more goals maybe a little bit
bigger but not that much bigger just
start start small
start with changing tomorrow morning
just tomorrow morning get that squared
away and then move on to the next day
and the next and move your life to a
better place one little step one little
victory at a time
rule number 37 be a good leader I'm a
veteran of the infantry and when I took
over a fire team for the first time I
made the mistake of drawing hard lines
in the sand this immediately alienated
members of that team if you draw a lot
hard lines in the sand and eventually
you realize that they're either
unrealistic or people can't maintain
them you have set yourself up for
failure what is that exactly so it's no
matter what we will not that blah blah
blah yeah there's the leg no matter what
we will we will win every single Road
marks that we do as a fire team in this
while we're while we're here on this
training thing mm-hmm
okay well guess what that's a that's
hard real there's other there's some
other fire teams that are also want to
win and and so you've drawn a hard line
and said that's not really a good
example of a good example it's like no
matter what we're gonna muster every
morning at 4:30 in the morning mm-hmm no
matter what and you know then the guys
are out on patrol until 2:30 8:00 in the
morning and now the next morning a good
no matter what a similar level it's it's
not good for them it's unrealistic so
you drew a hard line in the sand and now
you got to back it down so and all you
have to do is soften the statement a
little bit hey guys
to the best of our ability if we can
we're gonna get here every morning at
4:30 for muster there's a little there's
a little room to play there right and
that's that's fine so again I I there's
there's not a lot of it is not a
question here but one of the reasons I
think that that I that I wanted to talk
about it was because I think people look
at me yeah and even hear me on a
peripheral
level and they think all I bet Chuck
will just lay down the hard night
it's my way or the highway
right yeah and and the the opposite is
actually true and the reason that I came
to that conclusion was because I worked
for leaders like that and I hated
working for leaders like that so I tried
to never be a leader like that rule
number 38 find your purpose I can't this
is an expression that is vilified in our
minds beginning at a young age every
time a young child announces this
decision they are corrected the first
adult that hears it asked them whether
or not they have even tried generally
this confrontation will result in the
child giving their task
another attempt until their attention
span moves on to something else the
adult will see this and chuckle to
themselves with knowledge that this is
just a child who is yet to learn the art
of art and virtue of perseverance by the
time this child comes of age however
they will have been told by adults more
times than they could count that there
is no such thing as can't
it is interesting then to think about
how many adults seem to proclaim this
expression in their lives it is because
is it because like many things that
adults tell children they are simply
telling the child a general rule that
the child must follow but can be broken
once one has grown or is it because
these adults are simply repeating what
they were told as children without
thoroughly examining what the phrase I
can't truly suggests if you confronted
an adult that claims they can't do
something with the same question about
whether or not they have tried the
answer will almost always be yes adults
have learned enough to know that it is
unreasonable to say they can't until
they have at least tried once therefore
the real question that we should be
asking in responses have you tried
everything have you exhausted every
possible option scenario combination
tool and approach I
simply refer to the ones that you knew
of at the time he decided to undertake
your task I mean have you re also
researched possibilities that you had
known about have you determined whether
or not there is another person out there
that has performed the exact same task
you are attempting or at least something
similar have you exhausted this research
have you read every book blog journal
magazine bathroom stall and website if
the answer to any of these questions is
no then go back and try again because if
you don't because you don't truly know
if you can do something until you've
tried absolutely everything the fact of
the matter is that rarely if ever is the
answer to all these questions yes
therefore what is it that people
actually mean when they say I can't a
more accurate but more verbose way of
saying it would be I don't care about or
want enough this task or the resultant
benefits of it in order to do all that
is necessary to achieve it I was told
countless numbers of times by people
during my month of marathons that they
couldn't run one marathon let alone 31
straight every now and then when I had
time I would discuss what they'd said we
would jointly conclude that if something
they cared about and depended on them
doing so it would be possible the most
common example I used was if someone had
a gun to your child's head do you think
you could do it then
therefore the phrase I can't denotes a
lack of investment as opposed to a lack
of potential or ability I do not mean to
say that every person I had this
conversation with should have had the
motivation to run marathons it was
something that I decided to do not them
I merely wanted to express to them what
I am expressing here given the right
purpose and enough time you can rule
number 39 don't fight alone
everyone that's out there grinding
working driving trucks pouring concrete
hammering on a project building bridges
or building software sewing some
garments or sewing of field farmers
factory workers engineers electricians
plumbers and pilots and ground crew and
cooks and waitresses to everyone out
there working hard and listening to this
and just trying to get yourself a little
bit better today than you were yesterday
thanks for listening and as you meet
struggles and as you struggle to stay on
the path first of all remember you don't
have to fight alone reach out to your
comrades in arms call for fire support
when you need it we win the wars because
we stick together and when we stick
together we can overcome any enemy and
the struggles that you face when they
when they do try to flank you do what
Jodie did do what a soldier does turned
into the ambush turn toward the enemy
fire and attack rule number 40 pick up
the brass I think if you took out the
trash sometime you're the boss for you
and see that the trash is getting
overfilled you just grab it and take it
out maybe in your mind you think you'd
be losing respect but you
the addict in fact everyone looks you
know he's a good guy and you're working
and you still gotta maintain the
discipline the more that you treat them
with respect and respect you they're
gonna know that you're not too
highlighted there you know that you're
down to earth when I was a teen Koran
burtowski commander I picked up brass I
clean the ranges with the boys I would
recommend that kind of dude he didn't
make people think Oh jumpers does that
even better to do that actually do I had
stuff to do but what I'm gonna do
they've got grass with the boys and baby
relationships set the example they can
respect you for it
rule number 41 take ownership on social
media I see this a lot guys will hit me
up girls will hit me up something went
wrong with the client I stepped in I
took ownership they thanked me problem
solved
got it squared away I can't people are
surprised people are surprised that it
works people are surprised that it works
and again just to make sure everybody
knows it that alone doesn't work you
still have to problem solve the problem
without you cause with the client right
right
you you you gave them what they needed
late or it's gonna be late and now you
say it's my fault that doesn't mean that
you don't need to get it to em ASAP and
make up some corrective measures and
lower the price to do something so that
it makes up for the problem but the
worst thing you can say is well you
specify exactly what you wanted in the
order and therefore we couldn't get you
what you wanted on time okay we're never
coming back for business skin and what
angry this whole time and I'm gonna
short you money when we pay you in
anyways if I pay you at all
the next time you get into a situation
and you write down are you techniques
the excuses and the reasons that you
come up with look at them and then
figure out how they were how those
things were actually your fault and/or
how you could have prevented them
because a lot of times it's like here's
here's a here's one hey boss we didn't
get the mission accomplished because the
weather rolled in and we couldn't launch
on the mission that's that's the problem
now we all know that we don't control
the weather so when you will you write
the problem down we failed the mission
because we didn't control the weather we
can't control the weather that's why we
failed the mission that's my excuse
that's a
that's a logical reason there's two
deaths that's a that's a legitimate
excuse but don't use it what you do is
you say what could I have done to have
controlled the weather okay okay wait I
can't control the weather what could I
have done I could have come up with a
contingency plan I could have come up we
could have staged in a better place so
then you go to the boss and you say look
boss here's what happened the weather
went south really bad that was a problem
but it's a problem that I should have
done a better job taking care of what I
should have done was I should have had a
contingency plan
I should have staged closer to the
target area that I could have taken
vehicles instead of helicopters that's
my fault from now on I will absolutely
have a secondary plan this won't happen
again we can't control the weather
but we can control how we plan and how
we execute and this won't happen again
there you go so you take the most
outrageous thing that you know you can't
control you figure out a way to control
it and you take ownership of that thing
and it is gonna it's gonna make your
life so much better and by the way the
next time you have a mission and you
plan that contingency and you actually
execute and implement what you said
you're gonna do guess what you will
accomplish the mission that there's a
whole part of ownership that preempts
the problem if you've got someone that
knows if I know that I can make an
excuse if I know that I can make an
excuse then guess what I'm not gonna set
things up properly if I don't set things
up properly mmm more often or more often
than the other way I will fail to do
execute what I'm supposed to execute if
you have an excuse right same same thing
with you as an individual human being if
you as an individual human being if you
got some excuses that you can throw out
there that you can say I had no control
over that then you know what you say
okay what are my contingency plans what
could I have planned differently
let's eliminate those excuses take
ownership of your freaking life rule
number 42 get up early the reason I wake
up at 4:30 in the morning cuz no one
else is awake yet so that gives me the
opportunity to do things that I need to
get done
kind of selfishly for myself and the big
one in that category is working out and
it doesn't feel good at 4:30 when you
get up but by the time
7 o'clock rolls around and you've
already worked out you've already gotten
some work done and you've got some time
to say goodbye to your kids before they
go to school it's infinitely better than
sleeping in until 6:45 and you get out
of bed and now you're doing missed your
kids going to school or or whatever you
you you're not prepared for the day it's
it's awful something I'm sure you hear a
lot is 4:30 like this either just can't
fit into my schedule or if I'm gonna be
realistic I'm probably not gonna wake up
at 4:30 what do you tell people yeah and
there's people that work night shifts
and there's people that it's unhealthy
for them they can't fall sick no be
healthy get enough sleep but first of
all wake up at the same time every day
and if you pick that time and you start
waking up at the same time every day
that's very good for you it doesn't have
to be 4:30 it could be 6:30 it could be
7 I don't know what your personal
schedule is but find out a time pick it
set it stick to it and maintain that
schedule and that's gonna end up better
for you I recommend its earlier I
recommend that you go to bed earlier
because what are you doing at night most
of the time most the time at night
you're not working on anything super
productive you're just winding down and
watching stupid YouTube videos or
surfing the internet reading clickbait
stories right don't do that instead go
to sleep and then wake up early ruling
my 43 be yourself I was getting
interviewed the other day in some
interview and the guy said something
about like um you know it's impressive
how quickly you've built your brand
right and I looked at him and I said I'm
not a brand I'm a person I'm a person
what I'm doing is not what I'm doing so
that I can leverage people what I do is
just me and I'm just a person so if you
asked me if I would wear a rainbow
t-shirt I wouldn't know I've asked you
to wear lots of stuff would you have
I mean if and if you asked me but but
that's not because of I'm trying to be
something it's because that's who I am
right and I have been I had one of my
bros who I hadn't seen in a while and he
we met at a little place we'd go to in
San Diego and I hadn't seen him in a
year and a half and he comes walking in
and he sees me and I'm wearing the same
thing that I always wear pair of jeans a
victory black t-shirt and he walks in
and he see in a fight it was wintertime
and I was wearing a flannel like a
whatever like a whoooo England yeah like
a New England but like cheap whatever
flannel with the quilt inside of it you
know and um he sees me in like when he
sees me and this is kind of you know
after the books and the podcast and he's
another seal so he's suspect and he sees
me and I see his face and his face like
gets happy when he sees me and he and he
comes over and like those like a bro hug
and he says probably you're exactly the
same and I was like yeah man and he goes
I knew it and like that to me was the
best compliment I'll ever get is like
okay no matter what happens I'm not a
brand I'm not doing anything for you
know any other reason other than it's
just me and that's just just what I'm
doing and if people are cool with it man
that's awesome I'm stoked
rule number 44 put others above you if
you're there and you're in a leadership
position or you're just in a position
you're in relationship whatever and
you're doing things for the team you're
trying to take care of the others you're
putting other people above you in the
end you're going to win and you're gonna
win way bigger than you could if you
were calling and scratching and ripping
things and bringing them back to
yourself the end that person that thinks
that thinks that they're doing the right
thing or things that they're doing
something good for themselves but what
they're really doing is taking things
from other people that person they might
get a couple tactical victories along
the way but in the end the person that
puts everyone else first is going to win
they are going to win so it's it's kind
of hypocritical because it's like in one
hand it's like no I don't care about
myself I'm not trying to improve I'm not
trying to try and improve my station in
life but by doing that you will improve
your station in life and you improve
your station in life beyond anything
that you could have done if your goal
was to improve your station in life
rule number 45 be disciplined if you
want more freedom in your life you have
to have more discipline if you don't
have any discipline you'll end up with
absolutely no freedom you'll end up
being a slave to other people that boss
you around there's all kinds of problems
that can occur if you don't have
discipline in your life and the more
discipline you have the more freedom
you're gonna have so just that the
discipline of the sales will never it's
impossible to leave no it's possible to
leave there's there's retired seals all
over the place that are undisciplined
they've moved on and they don't care
about that anymore it's fine I don't
judge other people on what they're doing
like they're probably stoked to sleep in
and hang out with their kids and eat
breakfast in bed that's fine I don't
have anything gets that look for me I
want to get up and go rule number 46
give trust how do I build trust with
someone the way I build trust with
people is I give them trust so if you're
working for me I say hey you know I want
you to do this mission Patrick come up
with a plan I'm showing you that I trust
what your plans gonna be now I'm gonna
I'm gonna make sure that your plan is
good I'm gonna review it but I'm gonna
give you a lot of autonomy
I'm gonna give you trust and when I give
you trust what's your reaction you think
yourself this guy trust me yep and then
the way I build trust and reverses when
you make a mistake instead of me jumping
down your throat and hanging you out to
dry
instead I say okay you know what my
fault I should have given I should give
you a better direction here's what we do
the next time so now you look at me you
go hey I screwed this thing up and jock
would still trust me I trust him and
that's how I build trust I give it you
give it
I give trust to build trust if I'm
really putting in effort but my plan
maybe not the best plan you're still
gonna give me second chances to work on
better I will micromanage you more I
can't trust you as much we do a business
deal or we're in business I don't send
you out with the biggest client I've got
when it when I just met you and say hey
I trust you you know I'll give you a
little client let's say hey go go go
make this happen and you come back and
you say hey look I did it I say great
and you trust me a little bit more
or maybe you screw that one up and I say
okay let me review what you do what
mistakes got made and you say oh well I
did this and okay we correct that but I
don't I don't come down hard on you
because I'm trying to build a
relationship with you if I come down
hard on you do you even want to work for
me do you want me if I come down this is
pathetic you screwed this up this is
your fault
you're looking for another job I'm
alright whereas if I say okay let's look
at what we can do better then I'm
building the trust but can you know you
might be very trustworthy for many years
and then all of a sudden you go out and
you do something on your hand with a
client you try and rip them off or rip
me off yeah I mean we're not gonna have
trust for me anymore
rule number 47 make today count I want
to tell you something else
and I want to make this clear don't just
listen don't just listen do um I'm not
just talking so you know I'm not just
talking I'm doing and I don't want you
to just listen put this information to
work make today count every day go
forward get aggressive and attack
whether it's on the battlefield or on
the beat or in the factory or on the
farm or on the construction site or on
the website in the garage or in the
firehouse
don't hesitate step step forward and get
after it
rule number 48 start walking no matter
what you face
no matter how bad it is going to be when
there is a challenge and by a challenge
I mean anything in life any any
challenge anything that you're facing
the only way to overcome the challenges
that you face is to start walking take
that step every day no matter what you
are facing get up and start walking
rule number 49 follow your passion
chuckle when did you know you wanted to
be a Navy SEAL well specifically the
SEAL team part of it wasn't until I
figured that out but when I was a little
tiny kid you know five six the only
thing I can remember was wanting to be
some kind of commando you knew that from
that point from from birth basically
that was it because pops or an uncle or
grandpa was in a military or grandfather
was in the army and he was retired from
the Army but that wasn't really it I
just instinctively was putting
camouflage on my face and carrying her
on sticks and carving them to look like
machine guns when I was a little kid for
no reason so that's just kind of are you
from a big family do you have siblings
two sisters two sisters an older one
younger they'd they also go into
military or not at all so just you just
me
so from five years old you knew so when
you won in high school everybody's
asking you what are you gonna do after
high school you knew you're going in the
military yep and rule number 50 the
lasts only for a very special bonus clip
is work out I've pretty much broken down
my workouts into four broad spectrums of
working out I'm gonna pull on one day
I'm gonna push on another day I'm gonna
lift on the next day and I'm going to
squat on the final day the fourth day
and I just rotate those things through
and they're all based fundamentally on
some pretty basic exercises for pullets
based on pull-ups doing pull-ups and you
all you need to do pull-ups is a set of
rings or a pull-up bar and you can
handle that workout the push is based on
push-ups and dips
and all the exercises that are
associated with those types of movements
the lifts for me are lifting things from
the ground over my head and then finally
squat is based on squatting and there's
all different kinds of varieties of
squats you can do and I also include in
that sprinting and overhead squats back
squats front squats all those things get
incorporated in when I'm working a leg
day on top of those four on a regular
basis I want to train my my metabolic
conditioning so I want to do sprinting
and running and get my heart rate up for
very intense short periods of time and
then on top of that I do gut exercises
which is what we called in the SEAL
Teams when you're working your core is
the trendy term to call it or sometimes
you heard referred to as ABS but I don't
like those terms we call it gut get
something
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Jocko on how to be organized I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that except for the three-point
laning questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one how will
you make today count number two how can
you put others above you today and
number three how can you be a better
leader today
I appreciate any input or advice you
have on how to record and track
objectives in a functional in a reliable
manner as I'm subjected to a lot of
information each day week month
I'm definitely overloaded to remember it
myself
discipline equals freedom so yeah that a
few things first first of all definitely
write the things down in one place and
it sounds like since you're moving all
the time or you're going to meetings
carry just a nice little notebook with
you and write the things down as you get
tasked with them then on top of that you
have to have a master a list of some
kind either paper or digital I'm gonna
probably recommend digital to track
things overall in a prioritized method
so if you get tasks something in a
meeting in your little notebook you come
back you put it in the right place in
the master task list and then like twice
a day to consolidate the information
that's in the little notebook you have
into the big master list and then before
you go to bed at night you organize
those things by priority on the master
list you put the most important thing at
the top and that's what you're gonna
attack the next day that's part one on
how you get these things organized now
the part two is you've got to schedule
this stuff and actually I always say
this when people have trouble with tasks
put them on the calendar to you know
actually Jamie does that for me when
Jamie's got something for me to do she
just doesn't email me and say hey you
need to do this she puts it on the
calendar
so I look at my calendar boom there it
is I gotta go do this whatever this task
is done so put these things on your
calendar and that includes scheduling
time on your calendar so that you can
have time to consolidate your list and
do a review of your lists you know
whether that takes that probably take 15
minutes to do and I guess there's a
bunch of apps you can use and I'm sure
people will make recommendations but
there's a ton of to-do list apps
including there's one there's native
ones on all the different phones so you
could look at that as impossible a voice
recorder
you can either use the voice recorder
app you have or you can carry around a
little mini voice recorder then you can
just take notes with that and then you
consolidate those notes from your from
your voice recorder into your master
task list every day and then you just
gotta prioritize next acute raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion not
one drop of most self-worth depends on
your it's supposed to mean if you want
some jhaqo Willig motivation check out
the video next to me I think you're
gonna really enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
[Music]
it's an internal force